平版栗脇などです今日はこれからですね
テクノロジーの話をしようと思いますこれ
も触覚別に触覚に関するテクノロジーです
でそうはですね何もし
羽原ないで人間に触覚を感じさせることが
できたら
何ができるようになるでしょうということ
を考えていただきたいと思います
触覚というのはもともとさはものに触って
それもの遺産たということを主ための管轄
なのでこのを一つはものに変わって直角が
生じますもしそれをだけどもに触らないで
も触覚を刺激されることができたら
グリップがでかいやつを受けて開けてくれ
トゥループ
これ加工の話をしても意味がないので物理
的にそんなことできるんですかっていう
ことからお話
て少なくてもあのひとつは方法があります
それは超音波を使ったね
[ __ ]婆っていうのは同公園 i 周波数
非常に知らさ高いので聞こえないんです
けどもこれ以外はどの音と変わりません
であの今回はですね音が出てまして細かい
視聴ば神様じゃなく性出てあのー
そこのあのどのタイミングを調整すること
でこの部分ですね神のある部分に
で10日ての発想が短いので非常にいって
いう
ある部分だけ非常に変えてるん
てそうするとあの県警効果で号車という
現象があるんですけどもまぁ厚みが生じて
まぁこれ中身を押し上げている
なので超音波を当てて収束ソンパを皮膚に
当てるとやはり人間はそこで押されたと
いうことを山の近く4
人たちの長音パンツようだというのは非常
に smap ですね素早く切り替えて
ください
それによってものが増えた時の振動で音
皮膚の上で振動を再現してやると
もいろいろな食感が再現できるということ
があっ
しかもそれなりに遠くに飛ばし飛びまして
方からグリーン人間の旬の英語箇所を
狙い撃ちするということもできるわけです
じゃあ俺ができるというふうに音が変わっ
てくるかということをちょっと考えていき
ましょう
それを考えていくところですね切り口とし
て一つです
この穴触覚の刺激と風中の一平像を
組み合わせると何が起こるか
とかなと思った
でこの中にですね実行一体できたあるかの
映像です浮かび上がらせる傷っていうのは
いろいろなところで研究されています
非常にいいね松本駅
唐揚
ご存知のように昨今はそこに触ることが
できません
アペアを触れたらです増えてしまいます
次とってそしてもしれん
検査のセンサーで手の位置を継続してその
手の位置に合わせて映像員が出した
となんか触っているような感じ
ことはできますけどもでもこの段階では
平和人
でじゃっ次の段階で
もしですね
8 o
ものエイドが気に触れた瞬間に超音波た
妖魔話した超音波ですかちょっと手を押し
て行って食事振動衝撃の人とした時の振動
を再現してやると
まああの実際にモードが出た感じですはず
です
でお答えなんですけども超音波で果て
できる力を鍛えてそれほどを吐くなくて集
g 10
けれどもその声は奴と白金軽いものが落ち
てきたというような感じを
ことはできます
しかしませんこれ言葉で言ってもわかって
いで違っていないととしょうもないんです
けどもあの
一度とか私
約トップ
でこれができるというねじゃあ何ができる
かってことをちょっと考え
中野こういう風なスマートフォンとか
タッチパネルとか排気使っていらっしゃる
もこのタッチパネルみたいなものを空中で
実現することができる
をちょっと考え
これでまあ私たちあの実際作ったものかと
これ何やってるんだこれは4日寝てないん
だけど買っ当時の表面で行くスウェードが
浮かんでましてそれをました
指の位置方センサーで測って
まあそれに応じて画像が動い
でこれパッド出ると服のタッチパネルが彼
を張っていることにあげ
けどもう空中でなりますよねやっ
これ触覚話すけどやりますと実はその映画
に触っていうか
と言うか非常に分から市に明日感じなん
ですけども触覚バームと本当のメッセ普通
のあの
同じように
そうできる
けど仕組みですけども者の方に言っ
8風銘機賞とっ
てそれを失われますで8加減分
本分につ
タイプを打っ
であの剣城の部分から
それでえっ他の触覚抑え位
もうちょっと来
これもずっと近い赤虫てるやすくしたん
ですけども
まずここの部分で丁寧に部分が超楽しい
です
デートコラボチョンパを出して手足させる
とこの
とコースで少ない
でこれは大
ハドボですのでそれ以後反射板って版さえ
勝てて安心した
これによってですね光の色とあの力をと
会う
5000円の位置を継続してつの国を超
音波で分
やばい想像していただくしかないけれども
これ組の位置を登録して染まる
タードってくださいおおーー
プー中なんだけどもそこに方面があります
れてい
a 棟総理はないというねまあいいを数
ポンプちゃった1分けけども
あの
そこに目があるからよしても操作
でもこういう風なキーの入力をかも2のっ
ていうことあまり変わらない感じで空中
レイプことができる
じゃあ数字だけだってあの言われながら
ですねあの麺の上で撮って走る入れます
これを書いているかイレブンの振動も再現
していますのでなんか実際に本当に
メーカーという
でこれこういうことができるのですね何が
いいかなんですけどもまぁこれがあのう皆
さんだから広州の場所ですとハ割蓄え
ボタンとかってもあります行ったときに
あったわーりーふ
ますし逆に自分の方の体がすごいいかない
あのチーズしているとよっている途中のお
医者さんの結果違っていたりしてそういう
場合は掃除触れなくなっ
けども
8まあ自分でどんどん遅れ来ても
ありがとうございます有用なと思います
でまぁ女これは特殊なネイルになります
けれどももうちょっとですね2
7コスパてくればあのいろいろなところ
自分の出したいところにある
あっちパンで動かして
そういらなくなったらとか7また必要な
ところに貼っパンクですか
できて生活を感じている
いうような感じで正伊政府が a あっ
てるよ
けども
そういったよね
んですよいい
たというかと思います
さてえーと今まで
空中にで次元のさあれるペインを作ると
けども
た次に一歩進んで
次元の
3次元の物体さん
これもですね完全にこんなものが逮捕さと
いうものを体験するというから
けどを
程度の制約が付いた上ですこう
search 下実現いうことがでい
それはですね超音波を
あの竜年であの場に取り囲んでありました
レイアを気迫で経済してやると
ある特別な点だけ非常に黒いことが増えし
て
な状況をつくる悪い
であるお泊りと魔王
でもその一点だけじゃなくていっ
エニーノフたちの
入る
が象徴していると言うきてそこをサーク
ですよねあのー
山会話
7回わからんね
を下す手でもこういう棒みたいなん
ちゃんと動きましたやっぱりホーガンが
あっていう感じ
もちろん人実務でちゃうんですけども藤原
帰っていうのは感じた
で8
これがだからプログラムでどう影響するに
どんな形
連携者も作り額になる
小菅やらたいった
有効感じだからねっ
があっ
ことができる
でこれできると同じが嬉しいかなんです
けども
あの本的に
例えばあの
いろんなやるよとあると思うんですけれど
も
例えばその
3次元のデータ物関係の行動物とか ok
感じの方では
中に行くも
でもしれないんですけども
7巻次元の物体は既存の3人口ばっかで
だろう動かっていうとマウスを使った地元
使ってると難しいですねまた上手にできる
特殊技の能力持っている方もいらっしゃる
けども
と向かって
8できればですね感じゲー
一体みたいなところができたのかてて味海
が中であぶり出した
そういうような
と思います動画ですね触覚がないとですね
ただ今後ラフィート a 動画をかけても
それをそうなってっても難しいですね
ちょっとそれ攻略です
ちょっといればねこれ左側提訴ことです
持って作ってもの動かせません
これ今何やったかなんですけど越冬
右はものハグを動かしたね
左ば箱を動かしたのでもう一回ある街が
ちょっと見てくださいね
左があります
これ最初に上の子を突かれましたこちらは
したを使うんだから周りいたしました最終
的には同じでもにでは動いていたけれども
結婚後白雲をどの瞬間で使うんだか海上
ハイあのこの子の近くで箱を使うのか後で
初めて使ったからさ箱の動かし方これで
わかっちゃう
ことは
ただ判事円程度言えるを生ん発表かさ
情報が足りを
かな漢字源を
いうことなんですもここに沿っ書く方も
あるようだと本当に気でハンドル
いうのが降ったというのが
くれると思いますうさのである
はいじゃあ今まであるよねどちらかって
いうとせないと国を取得空というような
知ったんですけどももっとでっかくして
天井におっしゃったら区
っての音の考えるでしょう
建造ところでございますけど今机の上に
あるそしてそのした女児夕食
ところプロジェクターで
a ということして自分の
触覚まで感じ
まああの
そっちの書類ところ
0トルネコ床とまぁ側から楽しいという
ことですねまあいいんですけども実際あの
うこれです
あの部屋の中で特設の人特定の人だってに
一定の触覚が与えられるって言うとまた
いろいろな使い道があります
特に中などあのわっを離すとちっていうの
はコレ皆に声聞こえちゃいますけども触覚
ですと特定の人にその人に必要な情報だけ
を個別に与えるというと思いますことが
できます
で特にですねもうすごいわ例えば絶対バレ
ちゃ困るようなクレジットパートのば魚
みたいな秘密にしなきゃいけないような
ものを目の前で伝えることもできます
ちょっと声
今これを左手あー濡れますけどここにです
ねあの冬樹スターであの
これから送る文字の候補があっていく
考古学映し出されます
その中で見えない社交数は努力からの後
キーかっていうのを
ことにするとあの自分はあの今どのキーを
押されたら栄養てくれるのでそれを
書き取っているんです
で降雪つまりまあこれ書いちゃったらもう
バレバレなんですけども
基本的に恵まれ人が3年前でその一つだけ
遊具は私はこれをとっ
客席にこれ考えなくなってじゃあこれで
もうをのグラフ1学習できるのですかと
言う
怖いですけども
考え考えてしまうと思うんですけどもまぁ
実際あのこれ超音波な処遇ですねこれ
ぎゅっと握りしめた観客まで体験つって
いうのはそれ
もいろいろ状況を設定しております
例えば非常に軽いふわふわしたら風船
みたいなものを二人で触っているかなコア
なの
リッター8東武いる人を楽しくした
デフォルトで一つの風船をポンポンと一緒
に行っていうなものを再現したいというの
は原理的な不可能ではない
そうするとまぁ映像音声の下にあるかで
しかも一緒のものが変わるっていうと
八尾東えもんってだけ数をだけてよりも
いい
相手を感じことができよう4を
あとは例えばですねあの運転中に眠くなっ
たら触覚でとこしてある挙動
あの
あるいはれ重要な方向ですっ
まあドンキー d てとかいう高校を
教えることができるいうのは直角の柔道と
例えば堤家の声で見え人間ひなにー犬って
言われてプロパッと聞いてああ右口かって
いうとやっぱりどうしても時間を使うし
慌てたりすると右穴ってもう客足が力左
ちゃう
なんですけれどもあの抑えた方向に動いて
くださいっていうあのハイジャン
多少の訓練はいるかもしれない訂正しない
でいればあが何も考えて欲しい10件
ちょっとな動きの主義ということにかして
もあの子
といろいろまで
すると思う
であの
結局別で今までの情報技術というのが
ちょっと気がやっぱりねぇ10日3 day
近くで期目で見てわかるの技適人とかが
どうとかそういったものを
あのー
まーくあの共有できるように発達していた
と言えますこれから出てもちろんそれも
重要なんだけどもですけどもうこれからね
情報
というのは
女とか右は平
例えばスキンシップとすればあの
言葉も何も知らない提供もナイス pop
を安心させることができるし
サージをすれば
リラックスを
することができますストレスを解消する
ことができますそんな心のケアが長期的な
健康
あるいは人が豪遊もっと右左とか言葉で
言っています
というものを巻く触覚が刺激で行くをし
たりそれで法令さん
オールロードレーてい木行かせたいのか
こういったものがあってこれから重要くる
かと思います
they are の巨8だけですね触覚
をし影響するときにあるのかそういった
装置ををて後でしたものを d行けなきゃ
いけないということなので
a 棟
その時ですねそれ非常にあの1
ハードになりますので part 触ら
ないでしょうかが cfd ているいうは
あのそういうハーブを下げるっていうのを
焼く
あぺに考えます今日話探偵はですねあの私
の研究室提案あるいはでタップ
はいねそれをご紹介してお話をもう
ちょっとありがとうございましたha